conflit en irak du nouveau l'irak
propose un cessez le feu dans la guerre
des villes cette proposition est
assortie de cinq conditions
l'une d'entre elles laissent plutôt
sceptique bagdad souhaite en effet avoir
la maîtrise du dernier bombardement
patricia lacoste étrange proposition de
cessez-le-feu en effet où l'on voit le
président irakien saddam hussein posé
des conditions quasiment rédhibitoire à
l'iran en fait l'irak réclament tout
simplement l'arrêt total de la guerre
près de 100 missiles ont été échangés
par les deux pays depuis douze jours un
nouveau type de guerre extrêmement
impressionnant la fusée arrive sans
alerte sans déclenchement de tir de
décès à les charges explosives de 300 à
500 kg sont extrêmement dévastatrice et
meurtrière
et c'est à téhéran que ses effets de
cette nouvelle bataille se font
davantage sentir
l'irak a envoyé près de cinquante
missiles sur cette capitale contre une
vingtaine en retour sur bagdad
en fait l'irak veut toujours forcer
l'iran à accepter l'arrêt de la guerre
selon ses propres conditions
oui on vient d'apprendre à l'instant
même l'iran de son côté accepte aussi un
cessez-le-feu mais proposé par les turcs
cette fois et à condition que les
irakiens arrête les premiers leurs
bombardements j'ai l'impression que dans
cette affaire et dans la guerre des
villes on tourne un peu en